just by looking at you I can tell what's
wrong with you if you want to look your
best and whenever you have any
imperfection you're quick to blame it on
aging or stress but really that's not
all the signs that something is wrong
with your body if your insides aren't
healthy
that will show superficially that's why
when you come into my office I look at
you as a whole what warning signs are
appearing on you superficially then I
can figure out to lead to a diagnosis
before I spill the beans and explain to
you everything that's going on you need
to understand how the body works it
works in a system and it's made up of
multiple components when one of those
components doesn't work a lot of times
that can show signs on your physical
appearance if one part isn't working
another part of the body compensates
that's the way your body maintain
something what we call homeostasis a
balance of what's normal
wait one more thing before we start it's
important to know that while I'm giving
you a lot of physical appearance signs
it doesn't mean that you have the
disease if you have one of these all it
means is that you need to go to your
doctor and have a conversation something
you should be doing anyway if you've
been watching my videos boom these are
the top physical signs that tell me
something else is going on inside your
body
facial flush or rosy cheeks do you feel
like your face looks a little too red
not talking about the time where you get
sunburned or when your crush looks at
you hey girl you may have a medical
condition called rosacea rosacea is a
fairly common skin problem with 14
million people living with the issue in
the United States today it's not
something you should get really
concerned about thinking it's a danger
to your health but it's a simple benign
condition that can be treated by your
doctor wait wait wait one more thing
about facial flush if you're part of the
asian population you may suffer from
something called asian watch that's what
happens when you drink alcohol but
because you're deficient in the enzyme
acetyl-coa yeah that's a mouthful you
may have a reaction because you can't
clear the alcohol properly you may think
you have a thin chin you may think you
have a thick neck you may think it's
just a cosmetic problem and not that big
of a deal
I think it's a serious risk factor for
an illness called sleep apnea which can
predispose you to so many bad illnesses
including stroke heart disease high
blood pressure when you have sleep apnea
there's actually moments in the night
where your airway completely closes
whether it's because it's too small or
too big it
and when that happens it ruins the
quality of your sleep we've all heard
our partners snore at night or wake up
in the middle of the night because their
breathing wasn't right that sleep apnea
one of the best lifestyle changes you
can make for sleep apnea is to lose
weight unwanted body hair ladies this is
mostly for you if you start growing hair
where you've never had hair before it
doesn't mean you should pay a visit to
your spa but it does mean you should pay
a visit to your doctor why because that
actually has a medical word behind it
it's called hirsutism and what that
means is you started growing hair in a
place where men usually grow hair this
could be due to a hormonal problem one
of the most common being PCOS which is
polycystic ovarian syndrome when you
pair hirsutism plus abnormal periods
that's highly suspicious for PCOS a man
you got stanky breath bro if you have
bad breath or what's medically known as
halitosis it could be a sign of acid
reflux
during acid reflux the stomach contents
including food acid all get pushed up
into your esophagus and create this
nasty smell that you may notice when you
think you have bad breath a lot of
people think they'll solve this problem
by brushing your teeth more that's not
the solution the solution is to go see
your doctor some say the eyes are the
window to the soul
but what I say the nails are the window
to your health when a patient comes into
my office and I'm doing a physical exam
I pay extra attention to the nails the
nails give me a lot of information on
what's going on inside your body and tip
me off to some illnesses I should be on
the lookout for if you have clubbing of
the fingers that could point to a
chronic respiratory infection if you
have spooning of your nails that could
point to a chronic anemia process some
of you may worry about white marks or
lines on your nails and generally that's
not a problem but if you do have two
lines running parallel horizontally
across your nail that could be something
called Weirich slides and representative
of kidney or liver issues some of you
may find dents or ridges in your nails
and generally that's not something you
should be concerned about if that does
occur with some weird symptoms at the
same time that's definitely something I
want to hear about and could point to a
more serious autoimmune issue do you
guys remember what the body's largest
organ is no skin first things first you
know you have that little pimple and a
little scratch that never seems to heal
to you that may not be of any importance
but to me it's incredibly important if
you have a non-healing wound of the face
its squamous cell carcinoma until my
tests prove otherwise also what most
importance to skin are moles no no no no
not this type of mole
oh bloody mouth yeah that's the MA long
time most of the time moles are
completely harmless and benign however
sometimes they may represent a serious
form of skin cancer the way doctors make
this distinction is using the ABCDE
classification system along with dermis
Coupee when you're younger it's not
abnormal to form new moles however as
you age in your 50s and 60s if you're
still developing new moles that could be
a cause for concern and cause me to
investigate further hair it's perfectly
normal to see a few strands in the
shower but if your shower drain looks
like a baby rodent there might be
something else going on excessive hair
loss can be caused by an overactive or
underactive thyroid or something like
anemia so when a patient walks into my
office I pay extra attention to what's
going on in their scalp however have no
fear a lot of these issues can be
diagnosed by a simple blood test also
it's important to remember that you're
able to lose up to a hundred strands of
hair per day and that's totally
acceptable the eyes will give you a lot
of information if you look at the color
of the eye if there's something off it's
not perfectly white a lot of times
you'll see some yellowing of the eyes
and as a medical name it's called
jaundice that occurs when there's
something wrong with your liver or your
gallbladder I can also look below your
eye and get some extra information
things like redness or bags can
represent something called allergic
shiners which is a very common symptom
of people who suffer with allergies
springtime fall time very common if you
don't sleep well if you eat high sodium
foods if you're dehydrated the
appearance of your eyes is gonna appear
fatigue heavy sad and it's not gonna be
a pretty sight you know what they say
about big feet right yeah
ya know it's important to make sure that
they're not just swollen that could
represent a wide variety of medical
issues things like congestive heart
failure circulation issues lung issues
autoimmune things like arthritis all of
those can lead your legs to balloon up
but if you have some mild swelling at
the end of a long day of being on your
feet
that's something called dependent edema
and likely nothing to worry about a lot
of these signs I've pointed out may seem
like superficial concerns but they truly
tell me a whole story of what's going on
inside your body never be afraid to tell
your doctor something doesn't feel right
look right or even smell right if you
have any questions in the meanwhile drop
me a comment down below we'll have a
conversation and figure out what's going
on otherwise make sure to hit subscribe
and share this channel with your friends
and family those people over there a
little weird oh wait that's me the food
that's supposed to be in your belly
along with the acid gets regurgitated
back into your esophagus which creates
that nasty smell you hear look into my
you will see hey yo you got swollen feet
you know what that means right
big socks snug Footwear